round two you dirty freaks you stream
dot TV for it / oh all right we're back
um so crash you've been doing this
you've been this tank business longer
than the fucked up
no I didn't you've been in this tank
business longer than I've known you you
when when did you get started making
these fucking things um it's about 15
years 99 and what would brought you into
that well yeah I think it was with me I
was ready to choose to have a ASAP
nightclubs and I was in the music
industry and I'd uh you know narcotics I
was into drugs and stuff I'd like to do
that for you know but was it the time
was in you know in the 80s and stuff and
there's a music industry used to have
night clubs I used to do management and
then I wanted to do an audio later on
back in the seventies where the Stevie
Ray Vaughan stuff like that blues clubs
in the DC and then we went on like in
the 80s and had like you know Culture
Club the rhythmic sand everywhere we
count bass and then later on he went
into audio at Caesars and I worked the
showroom in there and I were the
Liberace and as a on and on is in a
different genre whatever you know shows
from then I we used to tour a little bit
and then these gigs and then I got a
band going there and we used to open up
for one of the bands I was touring with
and then we three guys so he had
interested in like Oh an hour to make
some be in this make it doing music and
got these studios and had 60 of those in
Hollywood and then finally uh I was done
you know I had enough of these people
he's strung out on heroin and United
right so they uh I've had it not a
functional though I'm not a stealer I
don't steal I'm a functioning guy back
then and I don't steal and I work and I
do jobs but I used to get I just like to
really get high you know as I was part
of what that you know what we did right
but so I was finally done with that and
I kicked the dope whenever we went on
out there to Vegas from Hollywood left
my buildings and I built a recording
star anch out there ten miles south of
town built a studio and there's my guys
come out when to do some recording out
there at this ranch I got there and I'm
in the back there I just
built it at my head now no there was a
good old water thing from what the
horses were getting water from or
whatever it was I had my head in there
and I was working on my voice and when I
pulled my head out all of a sudden I I
know I'm supposed to build these
deprivation chambers I don't even know
what is a deprivation chamber it so you
have you had like this idea Jamie keep
take this down off just go with the
screen so we could just see those those
photos around before I get distracted
sometimes well yeah yeah yeah yeah um so
you just out of nowhere had this idea
wasn't even an idea yeah it wasn't an
idea cuz I don't even know what it was
so just hit you and oh my god boys light
or nothing it was just all of a sudden I
had my head in that thing I thought and
when I pulled my head out I knew I'm
supposed to build deprivation chambers
and get ever people to do it I don't
know what is a deprivation chamber or
nothing I just built a recording studio
I got no interest I'm already doing what
I want to do I don't need a change of
life or I've quit doing what it was that
was holding me up you know so I was on
my path already but it hit me so hard
and at that moment I was relieved of all
my previous you know like I had a you
know you think back it's all I used to
have this I used to have that I'd build
empires and then collapse them over the
years you know I'd write work worked
worked really hard and then because too
much fun wrecked it every time you know
so I'd been through and at that point in
my life is saying bummer you know I kept
thinking about now I'm starting over
again and whatever and at the moment
when I pull my head out there this no
longer affected me at all none of my
past was so you lean into this thing
that they used to hold water hold water
for animals horses probably and you
looking in there and you pull your head
out and all of a sudden you have this
mandate you have to build sensory
deprivation tanks so you essentially got
a message from God I don't believe in
God listen pal he was talking even if it
wasn't God who was it was I don't
believe it anything I don't know what it
was I'm confused
it can does indicate though some sort of
superior but think about them into the
chain of events that happen now you
create that thing you know you you you
improve upon the existing dynamic the
existing design rather in a substantial
way you become obsessed with it you and
I get hooked up we make videos about it
we start putting it out you're doing a
podcast now more
people are finding out about it more
people are opening the senator I get
every time I go to a town like it seems
there if it's town it has a sensory
deprivation tank I get these offers to
come stop by and check them out and say
hey we started doing it because we heard
about it on the podcast it's a great way
to make a living we love floating we
love the benefits of it we just want to
thank you so much that happens all the
time in the movie man you're in the
movie is it because what happen happen
and what's going to happen is yet to be
because what's coming up still is is is
much larger than what's happened so far
with tanks with these chambers right we
think they're going to be every we don't
think so I'm pretty well sure of it at
this point because I have a I have a
realistic vision of the situation and
I'm convinced at this point that indeed
it is going to work you know and I don't
know how it all is going to turn out of
course but I I think that we're having a
chance now and that's why this situation
is so important to me this this
disinfection and this electrical and all
these these features that have to do
with health and safety this can become a
safe healthy and a just like restaurants
just like anything else that involves
cleanliness this is very important it's
a public service and then for you what's
important is that it protects the
benefits of this service where all the
negative aspects of it are eliminated
with foresight we're thinking about it
in advance and I think that's super
important and I really really commend
you on that and you also have these
really fascinating ideas about how to go
about that I mean your your your systems
of cleanliness and although the ozone
the filters and the the UV the
sensitivity of the filters it's all
incredible stuff incredibly detailed
stuff yeah we've spent a lot of time
keeping getting better we're just now
finishing up with a whole nother bunch
of stuff too that it's one thing after
the next thing I see when I first
started this is using apart from you
know this or that or whatever there was
like no parts for anything that you were
trying to make and like really try to
figure out how to improvise
whereas now though all of every single
component that we use is made for us we
have very specific providers of all of
this stuff that we've
refined over the years these containers
everything it's all very specific
because there's a an umbilical amount of
problem what's that term bespoke right
the custom made is that what bespoke is
talk I believe that is feasible placate
in the last one no no I will learn
through spoken alone be slow at this one
yeah I'm pretty support that's what it
means made to order yeah right order
right yeah so essentially these parts
and components did not exist until you
came along to design these exactly new
devices for chambers and figured out how
to get them all to work together yeah
it's been you know they give it to go on
you get it off all the electrical I mean
it's been a it's been a it's been fun
you know maybe it's getting like to the
point now - we're glad that we finally
are on the other side of all this stuff
and that it is a valid system that the
system now demands acknowledgement we
put it in there and that they can't say
hey you can't do this here that's that's
not true we could put one of our devices
anywhere and the authorities will allow
it because it's done to code that's why
when these places they're trying to get
through these trouble they're looking
for an exemption or a was the other word
they got variants these different things
they try to get all so it's not a
swimming pool so you don't have to have
any code or whatever these things aren't
cool writing is wins one pools have code
right yeah and because this isn't a pool
doesn't mean it shouldn't have code that
just means it should have a set of codes
that are specifically designed for this
environment which is what this stuff is
here this CCS standard here that we have
you see it so it's all that stuff there
then you read through this and this is
the reality of the direction that the
industry is going in that the
authorities are aware and and then
they're not stupid they understand what
liability is they they can't say hey go
ahead it's okay we don't care they can't
turn a blind eye on this anymore because
it's been brought to their attention now
well it's also been brought to their
attention that there's a lot going on
right now where people are being
investigated for for things like the
doctor
stuff we've got all this weight loss
shit that's out there and you know all
the self-help industry like things along
the lines of isolation tanks it could be
incredibly damaging if these things
become as popular as you and I think
they will be and the filtration systems
aren't good and people have nightmare
stories exactly why survive ins it won't
survive survive that's what happen
grossed out by it
yeah the AIDS came out these things were
not except the capable of dealing with
in AIDS even these these uh parasites
like the Cryptosporidium that'll take 10
days in chlorine to deactivate a Giardia
that's that's a new you know a in
chlorine and then bromine and course
these are not effective methods to deal
with well that and that's something that
people are considered for these tanks
chlorine and it's it's it's it's
actually bad for your skin to sit in it
like that it's not it's not healthy for
you like the skin like when you go into
a chlorinated pool and you go into like
a public pool especially that's heavily
corn in it hurts your eyes your vision
at end yes system it is you're breathing
it and when it's breaking down in an
action with these other materials these
methane's in the like I say it's
creating a politically by products then
that need to be eradicated you can't
just keep that's where you go to these
places they said hey how can you
switching that water out of there like
oh you know this guy on that thing with
the Hamiltons oh every four months and
you're going huh so today you're going
to take eight he says it's expensive
don't want to do it expensive so today
we'll take $800 your money and throw it
down a drain but yesterday we just find
it charge somebody come in here and stew
around in that stuff and I mean it isn't
right I mean there should be a
regulatory agency that demands you know
a certain level of cleanliness yeah
absolutely yeah I mean it's important
well it's important too that there's
there's ways that people can avoid the
negative aspects entirely figure that
out do it and don't have fast that don't
put people at risk but as I said before
we're talking about before there's one
things that I wanted to get into what
about like a commercial version of it a
non commercial version of a home version
of it right a version where you know
that's just going to be you using it you
know that you're not going to do
anything stupid you're going to take a
shower before you go in you're not going
to urinate in it you know that it's only
yours like you wouldn't need all that
other extra
jazz if it was only yours correct well
what what we would want to do is make
sure that whatever we build is built to
code mm-hmm
we don't want to put stuff into
circulation that's not code worth a look
if signage to happen to somebody
liability issues like if they if we
cheaped out on something and it made it
and then they you know okay but listen
hold on a second you're saying cheaped
out but i don't necessarily think it's
cheeping out it's only cheeping out if
you don't know what's going to into that
water if you know what's going into that
water because it's only your's it's not
cheeping out at all it's like do you
need to overburden your system do you
need to make it so it's unbelievably
stringent it removes all the path just
no you're not no one's going in there
but you know if it's just you don't you
think that would be that mean I'd not
only that'd be totally acceptable it
would be ethical
so as you tell the people what to do
well I could agree with that you know
the the issue is with us though is that
people they're there they're going to
take that that that system that we said
is for your home and they're going to
put it into a commercial space right but
you know once that these laws and all of
these standards are put into place then
certainly then we might be interested in
saying okay now here's how it could be
done that that would be less effective
say than the commercial version mm-hmm
but first we would have first what we're
we're very diligent about is to
establish these guidelines in the
beginning not to say oh well yeah some
of our stuff does this or that it's like
all of it does it's certified it's it's
perfect as it is now but the rest of it
is like okay we could do that
but it wouldn't be you know what it is
that we've taken so much time and effort
to to get right now we know all the
other components the less expensive ones
let's say right and we could do that
right but what I'm saying is the only
reason why you need all those expensive
components because you're dealing with
more than one human being right if it's
me that's the one human being I'm
completely okay with taking super clean
actions on it yeah it would not be like
I like to have the best
yeah I know but for someone who lives
you know in a modest way and can't
afford spend the massive amount is there
a way like I know that there's this new
thing that they're content yeah what do
you know that well it's a shower curtain
on a on an aluminum frame you know right
uh you know I don't know how they're
gonna keep that stuff from hardening up
there's a lot of things I don't know
about you know no I don't want it like
salt in the water yeah right and now
that I don't know how they're going to
keep that somewhere without getting a
hard I don't know how it's not going to
dissipate out of there you know I
haven't really studied into it but I'm
aware of certain limitations that occur
just in general when you're dealing with
this material right and do you think
that perhaps some of these other designs
are made from people that do not have a
long term history a long time history in
this sort of a business like they don't
understand exactly what's involved what
the like I remember the thing about the
dude who worked for Sumati he had
encountered all the bullshit before he
knew about when engine seized up he knew
the salt content was too high and it
would fuck with the spa engines you
replaced he knew he knew in advance what
it was probably when we talked on the
phone what the issues were yes and he
would come home and fix them so you
think a lot of these folks they're just
sort of getting into tanks now and then
they go hey I got an idea but they're
not foreseeing the potential hazards or
issues that would come from these things
yes some was that a good a good
explanation that that's this or I don't
think that they care that the ones that
I'm aware of some of these guys I don't
know I know because I I tried not to get
involved with these people because we're
on our own page we are trying to get or
not we're not trying we're doing it we
are moving forward in a direction I
understand what I mean you're aware of
these all these little companies that
are coming up and the good thing is that
it's making people aware of tanks like a
Kickstarter you know somebody sent me a
Kickstarter for that that Zen tank thing
and I looked at and I was like yeah I
don't know if I can retweet this I don't
know enough about it I don't know if
it's good if it's bad I don't know if
it's a good idea I made it on that
Google on your computer when you have
the Yahoo
uh-huh search motor or whatever it is
there is it I saw it on the Yahoo it
said Ozen 10 or whatever it's
interesting so it's the public has a
somewhat of a interest in it let's say
that E News is doing a some series on
actors and how they get into a peak
performance or whatever it is like this
and that and they want to include us in
that in that frame of this type of
activities that using energy deprivation
yeah you know it's how many celebrities
use have a sensory deprivation tanks
there's more more we have them coming in
more now really yeah there's something
you know that are very it's free it's
pretty cool too you know and there are
those good people as well the ones that
come in that are famous or whatever
they're they're never like a big you
know it's me or anything like that they
come in lope you wreck you know that's
why I come in dude Elton John sunglasses
big fucking feather hats shit I come in
big there's our world yeah you guys I
don't have the occasion where your
Gators there but the people then that
that that are a truck so what I'm saying
though is it's becoming more and more of
a mainstream are becoming more and more
popular and people becoming more and
more aware of it and I know a lot of
fighters use it Diego successively big
on it Jeremy Stephens who we talked
about earlier he loves it there's a lot
of you when that fighters that commit
not it was a very close fight but he did
not win but it was uh it was very close
it was very good it was an excellent
fight it was really close like at the
end I believe it was a split decision
well and at the end we were going man
who knows but I think the right guy 1 I
think Cub Swanson won the fight but it
was like I said it was super super close
they both put it all in it was great it
was a wild fight to watch these guys are
so skilled
mmm that that's been about kick with a
guy kicks him in the chin I watched you
walk out on a little clip and you're
walking out on this is a long time ago
and as you're walking you don't even
stop walking and you jump around and
kick the guy I think he kick him in the
chest or something and he goes out
immediately I mean it was like it wasn't
even you didn't even stop walking and
then that guy from Mott what is it
there's a law-and-order show the bald
guy that's like the captain or whatever
it is he was telling the story about you
and him
going through New York and there's these
hoodlums writers I got four or five or
somebody said so joe says what are you
talking into microphone crash oh yeah
sorry about that sir tells uh joe says
to him I forgot is do you know the guy
is the bald law-and-order guy he's like
dan Florrick
dad said he said you guys were and Joe
looks over and he says hey can you take
one of these guys and he goes okay I
said it's Joe jumped up and and not even
this never happened in New York I didn't
knock anybody out this is a completely
fabricated story and you're in New York
there's some who'd listen to me talking
about me I'm trying to dig nomming
happen did not have never happened
see this is the story he told me was he
was because he was might have been on
pain pills are you sure it's the right
guy ambien I don't know if it's the
right but you just never had a problem
like I did not beat everybody in New
York never kicked a guy down oh the
other ones ran off I haven't been able
to talk man no I haven't been in any
sort of a physical altercation since I
was in high school really yeah you never
did never get into a situation with some
guy getting a lippy mouth you got to put
him up with a guy on fear factor that I
had a grab but once I grabbed him shut
up and I just grabbed him held onto him
grabbed his neck late I didn't hurt him
I just he was too dangerous he had hit
some people before he had thrown his
wife down on a television show and he
had attacked a counselor on another
television show and we they had warned
us before he came on the show that he
was like it was very uh he's a
contestant and yes he was a celebrity
one of those reality celebrities he had
been on a reality show with his wife oh
this is the new one it was an old fear
factor they had reality shows back then
oh yeah man sure they had survivor man
started in 2000 I want to say like 2001
or survivor did rather huh 2001 and this
guy was on The Amazing Race which I
think was like 2004 or 3 or something
yeah I mean they've had those for a long
time grabbed him to get him just to
chill I think I thought he's gonna hit
me he kept getting my face I pushed him
away got my face again I was like I'm
not gonna let the problem with someone
hitting you is it's really hard to see
they're going to hit you if they sucker
punch you by the time you react you've
already been hit you know it's the
reaction times that people have are way
slower than action times action times
are way
faster so someone decides to hit you and
you don't see a comment it can be very
dangerous
and when someone keeps invading your
space and there they're not listening
they're violent they're angry they're
spinning your face or screaming if you
just let a guy hit you you know the
first punch is one of the most important
aspects of any sort of an altercation if
you get hit you get hurt that hurt
damaged and then someone can fuck you up
yeah I gotta be really careful and
regroup yeah so when someone these
violating all the laws of engagement and
he's also he's showing himself to be
very very dumb about physical
altercation because he keeps coming
forward I push him away from me and he
keeps coming for it again like
something's gonna happen if you keep
doing this you're not thinking about it
you're not thinking about what the
repercussions are you don't even know
how to fight and yet you still you
already know that your tiem uh Wow look
at that as himself but not just that I'm
looking at his physical frame I'm like
he's just he's frail there's nothing
there that's like dangerous there's no
explosive movement he's spitting he's
yelling he's red in the face it's all
emotional so I run out of gas in five
seconds if I grab him I'm just thinking
all these things like but I don't want
him to hit me that's the only one time
though definitely on time on television
have gotten in arguments with people
before but I'm a nice person man the
most part I can avoid most bullshit but
I didn't kick anybody in New York that's
what I think he said he said I did the
other ones ran off you asked him if he
could handle one of them he said yeah I
don't know what I don't know I don't
know what to say I don't know what you
remember I don't know who was on ambien
I don't know who is on third all right I
don't know I needed to be honest with
you but yeah I wouldn't do thought about
those that a lot of these people I think
that they're you know once you stand up
they take a little scatter off sometimes
put the choke on the guy that'll usually
stop you you know you should always
avoid a trivial altercation if you can
do it any physical altercation if you
can avoid it please do you're always
better off people cooler heads prevail
people relax they calm down they calm
down and get over a situation that could
have resulted in a murder I mean that
happens all the time where it's just
like people escalate and they get this
point they make irrational decisions and
they're super violent and then they go
and do something really dumb you know it
happens all the time people they get
caught up in their emotions they get
caught up in their anger they get caught
up and they're there
primal chimpanzee rage and they just
fuck up and they do something terrible
that's why how people who love each
other wind up killing each other I mean
where how could that even be rational
how could you ever kill someone
that you used to love and it all boils
down to some of the same issues that we
were talking about earlier people don't
have releases they don't have a release
for their aggression they don't have a
release for their frustration they don't
have a release for the energy that their
body continues to make they have all
this food they're taking in their body
their bodies getting fat because they're
not exercising it so this is all these
imbalances and everybody's uncomfortable
and people are agitated they're agitated
and easily irritated and it's all about
personal maintenance and it's all an
issue of personal maintenance whether
it's by taking yoga classes or what you
and I like to do by getting into the
tank or what some folks like to do they
just like to go for an evening jog I
know a lot of people that say that they
they go for a jog like Jamie's big
jogger you go for a run and it clears
your mind when it's over you just things
that seem so important 20 minutes ago
they don't seem that important anymore
an hour ago you were sweating all these
different things and now you're like in
a greater perspective everything's gonna
be okay
I was just caught up in a wave of
momentum of emotions and anxiety and
oftentimes you can alleviate a big chunk
of those just with physical exercise
there's like they say that physical
exercise is as effective as
antidepressants when it comes to making
people feel better yes that physical
exercise for a lot of folks is the
recipe okay what is a comedy writer and
he comes in and he says that what's he
name I don't know his name I forgot any
writer guy yeah he's coming right he
goes for a walk that he doesn't even
know run he says he runs he doesn't even
like to run but when he goes out knee
runs it creates a mental framework that
he uses to write with yes so he'll go
out and just go for a run to create the
mental mind frame that he's going to
work off of his material with yeah not
to get the physical benefits right mmm
is it I thought whoa that's a
interesting cuz I know sometimes about
riding my bike some stuff comes into my
head
oh wow I didn't think about that you
know right so I guess when you're in
this room you know exercising moto your
physical stuff is taken care of
well sure you're also you're pumping
your body filled with blood you're
accelerating all your processes you're
getting all your hormones going you're
getting all your endorphins going your
body's pumping you know you're flushing
out your system everything's moving
you're sweating so you're sweating
toxins out of your system allegedly I
don't like when people talk about that
because usually they don't know what the
fuck they're talking about now I'm
getting rid of all the toxins are you
really are you just sweating you know
what's happening here so I'm not really
sure which to but that's a lot of it
it's a you know it's exercise I think
that allows the mind to release a little
bitter and these come down perhaps when
it's the physical situation is requiring
more of you then and then your mind is
like freed up from creating problems to
avoid it's the battery thing we were
talking about earlier to it's your body
stores up all this energy and you don't
have a release some folks never have and
any sort of an explosive release like
months weeks you know days there's
nothing it never happens they have no no
release so their body's just like wow
you know it's designed for all these
different things that it doesn't get
used for it's designed so that you can
do manual labor it's designed so that
you could hunt for food so that you
could gather in farm it's designed to be
sturdy when required to be and when you
don't require to be it gets
uncomfortable you know and that's that's
the issue that a lot of people face in
this weird modern world that we've
created we don't we don't give the body
what it really truly needs
listen homeostasis especially a natural
state or something like that and I think
that one of the fascinating things about
the tank is that it allows a very
unusual type of relaxation it also is an
incredible way to absorb magnesium into
your body like magnesium which is an
important mineral it gets absorbed
through your body through those salts so
like epsom salts is one of the best ways
to get into your body you feel better
when you lie on that thing you feel
invigorated I lie on that thing for a
couple hours I feel like I just slept
like a really good eight hours sleep
like a
my body such a good I'm so good flavors
are so good that's what it's other
people they in what's interesting is
that people like it when they come in
and they do it they go oh you know that
was a very low percentage of you know
nothing we ever asked or anything but
most people say wow wow you know it is a
it's such a positive learning and the
the downside you know I don't even know
what it is
I don't think there's a downside but I
have had people come to me that that
were in a poorly setup tank like this
one guy came to me was hey I try to do
it but I was sweating I was like well
you're in a badly setup tank you're not
supposed to sweat you're almost supposed
to feel slightly cool yeah Jimmy get in
somehow slightly cool and if you're
sweating at all it's just the
temperature the water's too high and
that can happen it's happened to me
before I've had my temperature set wrong
or for whatever reason it gets warmer
outside Oh I emailed you about that
Riesling good leave the door open for a
while let some of the heat out you know
this is the number down one not you just
left it I left it do you want to stick
it always to it yeah it doesn't matter I
can do that yeah yeah
but it's some if it's set up correctly
it's an amazing thing and it should be
something that everyone at least at one
point your life recognizes or
experiences because I think that it's
it's an alien environment that doesn't
exist anywhere else in the world if you
could take a pill that could give you
the experience that you get when you're
full blown in the tank you know how that
you know that feeling that you get when
you're fully relaxed when you've
completely let go like an hour in or
something like that where everything is
just so chill and your mind is in this
like incredible place and you're you
know essentially just breathing and
floating when you hit that moment man if
you could get a pill that could put
people in that state it would be like
ecstasy people would be like trading in
the black-market they'd be like this is
amazing do the feeling that gives you
like the world goes away dude you don't
feel your body the world goes away and
you're alone with your mind in an empty
room you believe whoa
people would freak out oh yeah it's a
Felder they would be like that's the
craziest drug every right
it's freaky bro it's so illegal though
if you call with it you're dead it's
completely blacked out for a city yeah
and while it lost it is like a drug in
its effects but it's completely natural
completely safe completely I mean I
guess you could get addicted to it
because I think a person get pretty much
addicted to anything right you know if
it's worth doing it's worth overdoing
haha people say that about jerking off
then they get blisters in their dick
yeah the locusts come in there I don't
worry about the locusts then you know
and then you got to worry about you know
people get that way with gambling people
I mean people get addicted to bug a lot
of things that aren't physically
addictive as far as like the cellular
level but you get addicted to those
rushes that you get you get it motion
Aaliyah
we get addicted to fighting with their
spouse so a lot of people that just
can't help but they have these seesaw
battles within their relationships where
they get mad and yell at each other and
then they recover and they love each
other so much better because of the fact
they've gone through this this almost a
neurochemical where it we get upset and
then we go we get a hit from that well
interesting but we get bored you know
we're designed to go wild through the
jungle banging each other like monkeys
yeah we don't do that anymore so we get
bored so the way we keep it exciting is
start fights it's to shit I don't have
set makeup with each other yeah I just
think what what I love about the tank is
it gives you a chance to sort of step
back and see stuff like that gives you a
chance to step back and see like your
whole life and to be alone with your
mind okay alone with your mind to just
really get a good look at what the
fuck's going on it's such a good place
to go to well yeah it should be then
because it's like the regular world is
just loaded with stuff now it's like a
constant in order just like unplugged
not answer the phone or not not have
anything going on at all yes so very so
rare complex to get yourself somewhere
where you almost have to like leave and
go on a vacation or something but in
there you could just you could just get
in there and close the door and then
take yourself out of whatever it was
that you know what was where you wanted
to leave from you know and it can't come
back later
better prepared to deal with the
situation that it might have been you
know yeah I agree and I think it's just
it's so interesting to me that this
slipped through the cracks for decades
that somehow or another people forgot
about this and it was one of those
things it was incredibly fringe when I
came upon it I went to a place called
soothing solutions it's still opened in
Burbank and they have those Sumati tanks
and they do a great job taking care of
them they have a shower right there they
have a good real good setup and the lady
that ran it was super nice but she was
like it was on the verge of going under
like there wasn't that many people that
were using those tanks it was just those
are pretty rare it wasn't like this
super popular thing and I remember the
first time I did it there I was like
this is fucking bananas how was this not
something that everybody's talking about
everywhere you go and I questioned her
about it I questioned other people about
it then I would ask people if you heard
about it and I was stunned by how few
people in the psychedelic community
didn't do it we're gonna sell thousands
of them Dennis mic-n has never done it
I'm sure they're going this is such an
outrageous you know you're gonna do
everybody when I first did it and I
started doing it and going this is
something that it's graham hancock had
never done it and I know you told me
supposed to come to my house and do it I
was gonna send him to you to do it
alright next time he's in he's in
America I'm fuckin I'm dragging him to
one of those things it's like how can
you go around you travel all the way the
jungle do ayahuasca come it's right here
sit down
tapped into himself really good he's
amazing Hooper intuitive like that he's
a great great guy too just as a
beautiful human being and being yeah
somebody that really has a lot of
laudanum - fascinating honest
inquisitive willing to take chances in
even if he's incorrect occasionally with
some of these ideas the ones that he's
been correct about it's pretty
mind-blowing some of the implications of
one of the some of the things that he's
discovered and with things that were
talking about this on the phone on the
car right up here that gobekli tepe
situation where they've discovered this
incredible stone ruins from 14,000 years
ago and this is something that they just
didn't even know existed before they
didn't know there was a culture 14,000
years ago that was capable of building
something like this
and because the fact that it was covered
up 14,000 years ago they're pretty sure
that it was built at least that long ago
perhaps even longest covered up on
purpose was covered up on pavement they
said I think they explained how the ark
and this is all mainstream archaeology
folks this isn't some weird friendship
this is I mean pretty much completely
agreed upon by all these different
scientists that at some point around
12,000 years ago they covered all of
these stone structures and it's an
enormous stone structure complex of
these concentric circles and there's
these weird three-dimensional carvings
that are into these stone columns are
huge we're very intricate very difficult
to do especially back then when they
thought that people were essentially
just hunters and gatherers which is you
know they didn't think that people had
built cities back then so 14,000 years
ago someone or 12,000 plus years ago
someone had had the ability to do this
that we were unaware of until this
discovery and this discovery wasn't even
made until I can I think the 90s 80s or
90s someone found one of these stones
and they started uncovering it and to
this day they've only uncovered like 5%
why isn't that a focus well it is it's
just slowly but surely 5% uncovered but
it's it's a noticeable why why is it
society like informed about Kim
Kardashian's ass is huge and a lot of
people think it's fake that's it her dog
has got a he's got his paws probably
something's wrong something wrong with a
dog whatever shall I get the shoe shoot
oh that yes well it's just vein stream
television mainstream media is a lot of
is you know it's it's a business and
it's based on the the base humans the
amount of numbers look I've talked a lot
of people that work for paparazzi's that
work for like TMZ the work these people
they're just regular people that are a
part of this system that they get some
money out of and the they get some money
out of the system exists because people
are curious as to what Britney Spears is
up to they're curious as to you know how
Kanye West is going to deal with Jimmy
Kimmel making fun of them people just
get super obsessed by this stuff and
there's a business and feeding that
obsession so all these people that don't
take themselves away from the television
and
don't get into an isolation tank and
don't take a yoke and don't consciously
choose to not inundate their mind with
silly nonsense instead if they just took
a broader path took a wider view took a
more sensible approach to their life you
know I think we would see less and less
of that stuff you know it exists because
there's a void because there's a reason
for it because it's interesting to
people it could be a fad maybe if people
continue to you know get smarter it goes
on the course that we looked at earlier
in the podcast the court not the
courtship of eddie's father but of leave
to beaver we looked at Leave It to
Beaver and then look at things that we
see on television today in the
sophistication level of the media that
we produce the the artwork that we
produce is pretty intense the growth
amount is pretty intense so I think that
that is just that's the evidence that
people are becoming more sophisticated
overall there's still going to be plenty
of idiots
there always will be there's always
going to be people that resist there's
always going to be people that are like
involved in religious cults there's
going to be people that are ideologues
that have these insane ideologies
there's always going to be that but I
think that overall things are getting
more sophisticated people are becoming
more aware people becoming more smart
don't you think I'm hoping for that and
I believe that that's that's probably
correct and the tanks part of that and
some one tank can help a person I mean
if everybody you know likes say they put
them in these schools help these kids
you know the define themselves you know
that that's very important for people to
have that opportunity in that that
option mm-hmm to take and turn out how
they want to be based on what it is that
they think that how they want to be you
know I mean to do it because of your own
reasons
yeah and know what those reasons are and
that's one of the things about
meditation whether it's TM or whether
it's yoga whether it's going into a tank
when you're alone with your thoughts you
get an idea of what your thoughts
actually are if you live your life just
acting constantly on the momentum of
other people's expectations of you
wanting to be
like by these other people you can run
into a trap and you you you set up a
life that you didn't really want you're
fucked you're you're you're trapped in
this situation where you have a mortgage
you've got credit card bills you've got
student loans you have to pay you have a
bunch of shit going on you have to
continue to feed and all that and
especially if you have a family and you
have to feed them oh my goodness
then you're fully locked you and you
can't take any chances whatsoever and
oftentimes people make the mistake of
getting stuck and it is just a tactical
mistake just like it would be a mistake
if you got stuck on a video game just
like it would be a mistake if you
followed a map incorrectly and you get
stuck in the woods your life is
certainly some sort of a journey it's
certainly some sort of a journey and we
have to all be aware that when we're
making journeys we're not going to
always make the right steps and
sometimes you have to back up and try
again and if you're in a position where
you can't back up and try again you've
trapped yourself and the system will set
out honey pots for people to get trapped
in the system will set out the ideas of
retirement the ideas of the golden years
providing you benefits providing you a
healthy work environment why well
because they want people to work for
them they don't want people to realize
their own dreams and escape but those of
us a fucking pain in the ass you got to
hire more people and train them and they
want to set it up so that you stick
around stick around some sort of an
unsatisfying world it's up to you to see
that video game problem to see that
issue as it comes up on the map known I
think this is a right turn to see all
the problems that could potentially lay
in front of you and calculate your your
future and then also look around all the
people that didn't do it and look at the
misery that they're in and learn that
you don't want to be like them and then
look at the people that have kind of
taken chances and navigated their way
what did they do differently than you
what would objectivity do they have that
maybe you lack what insight into their
own mistakes are they willing to delve
into that you're not that you step back
and go you know I don't don't I just
don't want to look at myself that
closely but the person who's able to
look at themselves the closest it's
going to get the more rational results
well put you know because you're your
own architect you know what I mean
you turn out how you sort of I want to
be like Shaquille O'Neal shit's not
going to happen
well you know if you wanted to be like
is Satya black is really the odds are
slim that ya can't imagine if you could
imagine they found out the secret is
real that you could just become whatever
you want so if you thought hard enough
about being a giant you would just start
growing
if you thought hard enough about being a
woman you would just turn into a woman
like people like look at you like is
something going on crash you just be
like well I've been thinking a lot about
living my life as a woman so I just
started become a woman
you just do it like from a cellular
level unconsciously
totally what does what's going on here
with this that's ridiculous
I'm completely consciously isn't that
the idea behind like the the secret did
you get like um when that whole the
secret thing was going on and what the
bleep do we know and people started
really getting into the idea of
manifesting your own reality with your
imagination did you get a lot more
people coming into the tank centers we
think that was probably like kind of
into people maybe started to that group
was it called group consciousness or
some collect collective consciousness
yeah yeah you know I don't like that
and I don't like that you know motive
stuff about the water having a
personality or whatever does empal shit
I have a dark field microscope then I
studied you know a bit about water and I
you know I I yell at it or I'm nice to
it and I can't tell the difference you
know I've tried it yeah you you know
this you're rotten and it doesn't seem
to affect the water under my microscope
but he does the freezing I don't know
how he did it but what is it called the
message in the water
well it's Yamamoto he's a scientist that
suggests that the water is it like we're
water sort of I think is the the premise
is that yeah if you're nice to water
water is nice and this if you're nice to
people they're nice I think it's
something it's called hidden messages in
water and it's all pretty fascinating
but a lot of people think it's total
bullshit scientists think that yeah but
those the ones you got to listen to bang
because all these other people they're
seeing ghosts and shit you know the
problem is the scientists of the one
they're analyzing shit and looking for
actual results whereas the people that
are like really in this
spirituality and channelers and they're
looking to find a very specific result
they're not looking to just measure
these things you know it's fun you ever
done that thing with the muscle testing
and they push on your arm they put the
little medallion on you the Tesla
medallion or whatever no uh you know
your this is a Tesla technology or now
it's so okay they put a little wristband
a little whatever it is so I could never
understand how that works doesn't make
any sense to me right that's so one day
I'd sky shows up news okay okay let me
try this thing so I have a desk behind
me with a towel on it so next is a
proximity thing you gotta be within ten
feet of this thing or something still
has an effect so I say okay okay what is
this thing it's like a medallion there
my down yeah or a ring or Agneta yeah
they say something's about Tesla
technology and they put your arm up and
they push down on your arms people love
that's all bullshit those are carne
trick couldn't understand how it was
work so I took the thing now I say okay
here watch this take the table behind me
either I'm gonna have it in my hand or
not look behind my back and I either put
it up on the table underneath the towel
or I had it my hand right and when I
came back then all the chests were off
the guy had not a clue how to manipulate
the test so oh so he didn't know if you
had it on you so then he started doing
all his carny tricks and it didn't he
couldn't commit to them cuz it did I
uh-huh was well-nigh how to do them he
was trying to produce try it with me he
did it to my my co-host in the UFC and
he's believing in he had won on shit
he's telling me you got try this is
amazing and I was like what is it the
guy goes well I'm explaining to you it's
all about Polaris arts using all these
weren't the hilarity magnetism is all
about fucking voodoo Tesla he thought
telling me all this stuff and then he
said this this this thing we put on your
risk and make you stronger and I go
really and he goes yeah so he goes
alright um I want you to do this and he
like put made me put my arm out right
then he goes okay now resist me you know
and I've resisted him and then he's like
alright you're not supposed to be able
to resist that I was like look man
you're making a mistake you got bad
leverage in pushing debt you're trying
to push down on my arms you're not big
enough
I can hold my arms out there like that
it's lift up yeah I lift weights this
shit ain't gonna work and then he goes
alright now I want you to put this on
you know
tell me if you feel like stronger I go
am i stronger you're not gonna get me
stronger from a fucking little rubber
band around my wrist this is ridiculous
I go you're standing in a different
position I go you're doing it
differently okay you were trying to get
closer to me before and now you're doing
it further away from me which you know
you have less leverage this is stupid I
was like this is dumb as fuck man
parlour track dude got mad at me man he
was really upset at me face started
getting red I go listen man there's no
scientific basis for any of this shit he
was 100,000 off which can't be wrong
turns out they were wrong turns out they
sued and turns out there's a
class-action lawsuit and all those
fucking people got their money back
means like a it's a big deal yeah it's a
parlor trick total or shit but I talked
to fucking athletes that's War II worked
they do that the people believe you well
that's why I like you say was it the
chamber though is that like they do all
those a hoax E or this they tried this
or they they tried to acupressure and
then they do these shows on TV and they
try to you know discredit yeah he's a
natural well you can't discredit the
chamber they've never been able to come
it wouldn't want to first of all it's
it's so natural it's so natural and so
positive and you look at it so ingenious
in its design ten effect with the
absence also effect does something it
helps you do something with yourself and
I mean what else is there that does that
hardly and it's super relaxing just
super relaxing we could all use to relax
fuck I know I can goddamn it
let's make I could fuck it used to relax
away these people are coming at they're
at a big hurry to relax yeah they're to
hurry up roxtor I have an hour yeah get
in there quick we give them two hours
for 40 bucks
that's amazing by the way you have the
best fucking rates man nobody has rates
like that everybody else is like I've
heard fifty bucks an hour I've heard
people saying well you know there's no
money in this is no profit in it so it's
we have to charge this much just to keep
the doors open but what you've always
done is I mean I can't tell you how many
people have gone to the float lab and go
to so cheap I was like yeah yeah in
comparing like in my town it's a hundred
fifty bucks for an hour like I've heard
that I've heard a hundred fifty bucks
you know for an hour what's the most
expensive you've heard someone charge I
know
20 and stuff I don't ha see just if it
bums me out because it's not cool to
charge people like that to try to you
know if you if this is a person oh you
know you could charge more well so what
I don't have to I don't well if you have
an initial investment you build an X
amount of tanks and then you have a
place where it makes sense like as far
as like the amount of rent and then you
just have them filled all day long it
can be profitable I mean you're not
going to be Rockefeller not gonna but
you're not trying to do that you're just
trying to spread this shit try to
accommodate the people in general not a
specific group of people like I remember
I saw the club's I always have the jello
shooters for a dollar I have a dollar a
beer always a dollar draft always and
then I have a dollar shoe almighty ops
is a dollar you know I could see people
that the money is a thing for dealing
with regular you want to have what is
your objective you're trying to make is
this your money thing or trying to
provide a service and and created which
community like that come to you like I
never hear anybody I've never once heard
anybody go do you think oh you know what
crash was rude the place sucked the
tanks were expensive no one's ever said
that they always say Oh crash is so cool
the place is so nice I love it there
it's great like no one has any
negativity well that's that's like Ian
so handsome look at him over there
beautiful bastard there's a bring it the
girls I like that oh it's good move
Ian should be like oiled up and
shirtless you'd attract dudes and girls
is that people coming in from all around
to use those tanks yeah did he even use
this tank yeah does it need to the
tainted Ian uses oh hey that's it not
doing another thing we have a little
chamber I want to give it away we we
updated that thing - okay it's all black
now we made the entry we change the door
out now it's a it's a black door and
it's inlaid and we've taken we've fixed
it all up and oh that's awesome so
something with it let's do that look at
them tell me what we need to do and
we'll we'll give it away
let's do that one cuz I gave away my
last tank yeah my samani tank I I had a
random drawing online people send me
their emails and I just went I spun I
like did the thing with my laptop and
I'm like clip okay this guy and then I
just sent it to that guy just total
random decided to send it to this one
guy in San Diego and he
my tank well this is Genesis yeah we we
tuned it all up it's an outrageous
vehicle man it's it's a cool rig and
it's uh you know it's your old thing so
is it how much is a salt cost it's funny
about that too so you get you thinking
about the epson salt magnesium sulfate
SP grade right yes it depends on where
you get it at even though it's labeled
the same way USP is a pharmaceutical
grade mm-hmm there's a quality is
different like if you know any way you
could get it at the home I mean at the
bed bathroom beer 99-cent store for 50
cents a pound right yet it's you know
it's not the highest grade even so you
got to get it from you you hook me up
with some chemical companies that's what
I get it with right yeah yeah and it's
like 75 80 cents a pound or something
there which is you know but so you
figure it's like a thousand pounds it's
800 bucks and who'll but that chamber
though is in primo shape we have it all
fixed up and one day we'll figure out
what we're going to do because you know
we're going to be talking more about
this this venue in Westwood yeah so
you're going to open up a place in
Westwood when it's going to be open for
the public that's a good question we've
been working on it for a while now
because of the a few details with people
that we needed to get behind us how many
tanks do you have right now in Venice -
two that's it that's it Wow
and then take place in Westwood we'll
have ten ten oh so - and in Venice are
booked up like deep into August right
yes and would be if you probably had 20
of them you know in turn note there's a
lot of calls and we don't make an effort
to utilize any you know like there's
been some shows on the TV shows want to
come in we have any but we don't have
any time right that's like so oh they
want to come and film there or something
well vice film there that was cool in
Hamilton Morris I remember he contacted
me after his over said it was one of the
most life-changing things he's ever done
he ate a pot edible and got into your
tank and just like changed his world
what changed our world - that really was
it was an extraordinary opportunity for
us then - to have the chance to to show
some people what this was about he
really informed a lot of people you know
you know you and him and
other people that you know that mostly
it's just you and I don't know who else
is really pending on well that was his
first jaunt yeah his first real run in
the tank but he's his whole thing that
pharmacopoeia show that he does and
really was fascinating he got a lot of
really fast in the episode it's really
cool well produced episodes where they
covered a lot of different kinds of
psychedelics a lot of different kinds of
subjects but this the subject this this
whole thing where people are getting
curious about altered states of
consciousness is increasing and growing
and even more so this idea that you
could do it in something like the tank
where it's totally natural and safe and
healthy you know don't worry about it
and so I think I think it's all part of
this new sort of expanding of our ideas
that we're seeing in today's society
it's an expanding of what what is you
know what do you have in your life
what's in your world you know you know
what are you adding to your body what
are you adding to your day what how are
you expanding your your consciousness
your point of view these are all new
things to new new considerations these
are points to consider that in the past
really haven't been left up to the
individual exactly like you go along
with the tide you know but now you can
you could grab ahold of yourself and say
listen and I'm going to think about this
the way I think about it and then make
the decisions to you know have be versus
you know not a victim anymore you know
isn't victim all there this there that
you know they are what they are but you
know you with ability to recognize your
you know that you have you are capable
and that you are potentially just
getting started I mean we're all yeah
young if we want to be if you want we're
certainly all a work in progress and you
know let's hope the more you keep
improving yourself the more you enjoy
this process of life so we're talking
about like people trying Pilates people
love trying to shit you know I get into
archery recently it's fun it's like
something exciting about learning
something you know you don't
know that much about it and you can see
your progress you know maybe you know
take up a martial art or soil or a skill
yeah
something you can start doing something
sewing I mean that I don't know anything
I mean it but but the you know it's good
to have a balance yeah I know that it is
it's it's super super important to have
a balance and also to find things in
your life that stimulate you the more
things that I do that excite me and
stimulate me the more things that I do
where I'm learning new stuff you know
it's just I get into things and those
things that I get into wind up in rich
in my life the enthusiasm that I get
from pursuing some new subject that I'm
interesting is that cool when you're
learning what you want to learn about
which is why I wanted to talk to you
about these crazy screens that you're
trying to hook up these tanks with this
is the thing that crash was going off
about forever was these screens that
would suspend above the tank and emit
the lowest amount of light possible so
you only saw the image you didn't see
the actual screen itself or the border
itself you just saw the image in front
of you and in that sensory deprivation
state where the only input it was coming
in was what you were catching off the
screen what you were hearing from the
program that your mind would be way more
easily a way more able to absorb the
information it's a trip we after five
tribes military providers we used to get
this thing finally doing what it's
supposed to do who says anyways it have
been a difficult killer to be contained
that image in that area that it has to
be in with Fort so that that is very
because you know you're laying down
looking at it and one of the first
things that we figured out was because
you're on your back
right is it there so we take it and you
go like this Zoop and you go Boop and as
soon as the screen changes around you're
convinced that you're standing on your
feet and looking forward on your feet at
the screen really oh this is one of the
first things and then there's some other
stuff here that you know that so when
you're lying on your back and you're
watching the video you think you're
standing after you take the video that
you make them but there is no video for
this really it's like mostly your brain
you don't want to see gone with the wind
or you know you get your your whole mind
it just yes patterns or movements or
whatever we've been working with
different stuff as much as we can with
the time we don't have enough time but
we come back we have a we have a
strategy then to start to produce these
programs involved in this system but the
the initial what's occurring there with
that is then you know that's that's the
future you see this what we explain it
though there's a screen that's hovering
over our face uh how when you're laying
on your back and how wide is it it's the
one we have now is 19 inches because the
material required to build it they can't
get it any big now though there's 32
inch screen material I can get it to
make the to make it 32 inches across but
is their size that it's no longer good
because you have to know that blackboard
it's all black so the whole thing is a
screen right it the the the image will
move around within the screen so you
have it all black we're working on
something you know like those tiles hmm
in the bottom so if you're in a dome now
and you're laying them back on your dome
and those tiles are underneath you so
that the bottom is waterproof of course
but you use it lights on the bottom a
projector or whatever you know on the
bottom and in a dome you're laying on
your back and the dome then is all
filled in with screens oh and the bottom
so now you're laying in this thing and
you're flying it through space and a
dumb the upside everywhere you look and
then it flips you over but wait a minute
wait a link you're lying
but you can see you can't see through
the water yeah it's clear as a bell so
the but wouldn't that ruin the whole
idea of a sensory deprivation oh no it's
a whole nother thing light underneath
you see light you're flying but you
can't turn behind you and look behind
you if it's screen everywhere you're
enclosed in it this is riveted here I
don't really want to okay but if you're
lying I'm confused
sorry yeah but you keep interrupting or
if you're lying on your back you're
looking up right what difference does it
make what's behind you you're not going
to see that well you you want to know
that it's not it's something because
then you're flying you're suspended you
look around you're in the air I mean
underneath you is cool too
if you can have the whole thing
encompassed in you Shoji I did wind up
looking up but you can't when you're
lying back like that you don't know
which ways up you down no you would be
it would make you think that you're on
your stomach looking up at what's you
know I mean looking down that what's
actually up you don't your mind is
twisted when it twists you have no
reference right so when you move you in
there you are under the impression
that's the position you're in
well sometimes I don't know where I'm at
when I'm in the tank when I sort of snap
out of it I've never moved I don't even
know where my feet are facing yeah
bottom ever fallen out or anything like
that where you take off any which way or
no yeah you feel like you're flying
through space
see now that kind of stuff is like
freaky you can't tell people about it
cuz they're going alright then well you
do
I think they froze me out because I used
to talk too much about stuff that was
probably froze yo who's they I don't
know who they are
fucking government man Oh area 51 those
guys don't have nothing to do with me
I'm more of a you say but they're
controlling you with chemtrails spraying
in the skies nanobots up there dripping
down that nano stuff now that's a weird
stuff huh we won't go there don't go
there yeah yeah but this other thing I
had to do with audio mostly the audio is
what's the yes in the audio actually met
you had some demonstrations where I made
the water move oh the water is moving
it's a cymatic frequencies we've figured
out how to them to create the patterns
of sound see we're made out of frequency
based material maybe you bro I made a
twisted say yeah yeah exact sex appeal
is there's all the file but we're made
out of frequencies like would even see
based materials everything is it's
moving oh you mean like strings every
the idea of everything moving at a
different vibration matter is comprised
of materials then that are you know
mm-hmm unique like your liver is
different than your your kidney you know
the frequency of the deliver or the
material that the kidneys made out of is
be different so the cells then that
would be used for these purposes with if
you could see what they tell you that
the replication of the cell creates a
depreciated version in other words as
you aging right yes exactly okay well
what if instead of a depreciated version
of the previous one what if you did
better but if you created a cell that
was
better why wouldn't you if you already
understood but happened to do that well
this is going to be a tool we have this
the sensors now see I was talking about
the brain thing the Germans are getting
me with a cap there what's the neuron
the brain thing with a cap that has the
electrodes on it like a swimming cap
well it's not I don't cap no it's got
electrodes on it it's a cap that goes on
your head okay they haven't built it for
me yet but I've discussed it with them
and they understand that they can do it
based on some thing they've done in a
bathtub somewhere but the the sensors
then you see as they're connected to you
you input information see that's the
other things the sensory of of what's
going out and what's going into you and
then monitoring what occurs based on
this input this is what that thing is
all about but you know I don't want to
get too deep in there because it's kind
of like in the future right now and then
so your idea is to combine sound with
images to essentially tune your body to
a different frequency and that could
potentially change the way your body
produces cells absolutely that's a whoa
interesting analogy of the situation but
indeed there's a lot of evidence to you
know a lot of evidence about meditation
in the mind and the effect on the mind
the physical effect on the brain and
that what is meditation it's tuning into
a certain type of frequency atherton
certain type of mindset turning into a
certain mentality tuning into a certain
energy that the mind is is focused on
and that that actually has a profound
effect on the very brain itself that's
pretty interesting stuff a super
interesting this so that makes something
like what you're saying actually viable
oh yeah
know that we have a group of people that
are willing to give us the money for
that you know that's we have the
resources now to complete that you know
in some sort of period of time once we
focus back to it we've been trying to
get this other stuff done so then we
could get back to this stuff but that
technology that we have built and
patented as well is extraordinary and
that that takes this thing to another
level I mean this is what it is and
that's why it's so important as well
these vehicles that we're producing now
not only will they be used for this you
know
stuff that we've been talking about here
in regards to relaxation and so forth
else it will eventually in the future be
used also for you know other health
benefits and learning and a whole array
of various positive features that this
the positive benefits of it absolutely
influence that human and to be used in
conjunction with a lot of other things
in your life
proper diet exercise diet meditation all
these things absolutely that is this
there is no there's all this silver
bullet it's a it's a comic like you have
to get it should be everything it is
important food your intake their mind
your rest or whatever it is it's all
like that if you can get yourself you
know balanced out and we have a lot of
room for growth you know like I said
we're just getting started as a I think
that the the species itself humans that
we are are just starting to understand a
little bit about what we are we don't
know where we came from a very good
point yeah yeah we are starting to end
we discussed it in the previous podcast
about the just just the couple
generations between us the people that
lived in the 1940s during World War one
the World War two rather than dropping
the first atomic bomb and then people
before that in the 1800s it's just a few
generations you're just dealing with a
few 70 now how this retinol works and
you've seen this in the back of the head
it's in the dark or the eyes eyes
changed around the information somehow
and it comes out there and then you
think it's out there when it's somehow
back in here being interpretated well
but we're talking about earlier with
meditation there's a study if you if you
google how meditation changes your brain
a neuroscientist explains there was a
group of Harvard neuroscientist led bar
this woman Sarah Lazar who's a PhD and
they they were interested in mindfulness
meditation and they've reported that the
brain structures they monitored brain
structures change after only eight weeks
of meditation practice eight weeks of
meditation practice and your brain
starts branching out in a different way
starts truly expanding
your consciousness you think of
expanding your consciousness being some
sort of an airy-fairy thing well no it's
measurable like it's expanding your mind
itself what is more important than this
I'd only is anything more important I
may not it is that did is the premiere
opportunity yeah to to to do something
for yourself and if you can expand your
mind believe me all these people that
are trying this if they tried it in a
tank it would be oh so much more
effective it's it's it's it takes so
much it's like you know can you uh you
know can you get across the country
riding a bike you certainly can can you
get across faster if you ride a plane
fuck yeah okay and this is the
difference it's like you can get there
on a bike you certainly can good luck
good luck all techno shamanism mmm you
know in a lot of ways acknowledge II to
to to create like they say these monks
they're out there trying to get these
dated levels yeah is that 20 years in a
side of a mountain meditating or you
could go jump in the chamber and get
yourself sorted out and you know much
faster well yeah I mean I would like to
see what those Kundalini masters see
when they hit that highest level because
I do believe that they can achieve
psychedelic states when they're doing
that route they're not leaning people I
don't know they are but some of those
monks up there in these uh monasteries
or wherever they're at they use these
frequencies that they produce with their
uh yeah notes and stuff to affect them
as I'm not well Duncan Trussell knows
how to do that he'll he'll he can do
those chants those crazy Buddhist chants
he hasn't memorized it's very freaky
when he starts doing it does it take him
in just some art as he go in his mind
yeah come on he he also the freeing
aspect of chanting and just the
harmonizing and saying all those things
you just sort of like get into this
state Ross I mean if it puts you into
this
vibe Duncan benefited tremendously from
the tank though Duncan has been my
friend for a long time and one time way
in the past he had a bad breakup called
me up from a hotel he was at some hotel
he's like dude you know my girlfriend
just kicked me out we had this horrible
breakup it just went awful and I'm like
he was living with her he's like I'm
literally homeless
and I said hey come live with me I got
an extra bedroom so Duncan came and
lived with me and was going into the
tank that you designed and he would go
in the tank every day he lived with me
for like um a few months I don't know
how many maybe four or five I don't
remember
totally until he got back on his feet
again but he sorted everything out in
that tank and he would tell me about it
he was like dude he goes I just can't
wait to get back in that tank and every
day I just get in that tank and I'm
figuring it out more and more he's
figuring it out and he's not reading
what they said or it goes in there and
it figures it out I've never met a guy
who got his shit in order quicker back
quicker than from a devastating breakup
then Duncan did was willing to him to go
in there and and and do the work
required to get done with that he also
realized what had gone wrong like really
quickly instead of like wallowing in his
own self-pity or trying to distort
reality to sort of just sort of be more
easily digestible you know like it was
all her she's crazy now sort of he saw
the whole thing
West on it he didn't put any twist on it
you saw his part in it as well as the
other one in yeah and then from then he
went on to becoming a successful
comedian me it's crazy it's just like a
slow build from there
he caught caught that momentum but it
was a lot of it was based on doing going
that in that tank having those
experiences on a daily basis it's it's a
it's a fantastic system for people to
then you know access themselves yeah I
mean that you know that the rest of it
is you know it's it's a it's crapshoot
you really never know what you're going
to run into in there but you do always
have that opportunity to look at
yourself and you know and sometimes I
don't even do that sometimes I just
relax sometimes there are times where
like you know I'll come home and maybe I
come home from a show and everyone's
asleep and I say I just need to go in
there and chill for a bit and I'll just
go in there and just chill like I'm done
I'm tired I did work I did shows I did a
podcast I did some writing I maybe even
worked out already - I don't have
nothing to think about
I just
chill and so I go in there I just the
checkout loading man less this the the
lightning of the load the releasing of
all those muscles and the I get out of
there and I feel so good I feel so like
calm and chill so important man it
should be everywhere they should have
them every gym should have them
community center should have them
schools should have them university
should have them it should be just as
important it's having a basketball court
you got a basketball court you don't
have a tank the fuck you guys crying
teaching people shit you know you need
to get a goddamn tank room son well
we're going to I think we're going to do
that what we can do to make that all
happen you know these schools and stuff
these kids are at once again not you
know if things go the way that we we
hope they go we're all about providing
these vehicles for schools and you know
old people or veterans or these veterans
get a lot of benefit out of this too
they get that PSD whatever it is EST
yeah those traumatic stress disorder
they say that the chamber is is the one
thing that helps them up you know think
they're all getting the Kim that you
know the medication and so forth but
other than that they don't really have a
an option you know and so this is a
thing that would be very appropriate to
offer these these servicemen and women
they come back and have troubles dealing
with the framework of their situation
when they get back here they had little
opportunity to go in there and
investigate the you know because it's
already done
you can't go in there and erase whatever
it was it's bothering you but you could
go in there and come to terms with
whatever it was realizing it is it's
done it is what it was just like any
other problem that people go back to I
mean at some point it's it's up to you
to release yourself from that obligation
to get upset or feel bad about something
that didn't go right in the past you
know and that's a huge point because
people
to find themselves by the past instead
of thinking about who they are now and
set up they still look back at a mistake
they made and don't just get past that
mistake grow and learn but dwell on it
think it defines them it's the worst
thing I met some guys in band use as
singers I've only met him twice two
different times years later both times
he started telling me about the story
about what happened to him when he was
in this anything in this poor guy has
gone on all these years and he's still
focused on the worst situation that he
ever had to live through yeah and he's
so attached to it
well some guys get one breakup and
they're done some guys one breakup in
their 20s will tank them for a decade
I've met guys like that that yeah you
know I came out here with Charlie and
you know she fucking fell in love with
her trainer and dude Sally still move on
what is that and fucking years ago oh
well you know changed my life bro but
target are you so disappointed I can't
trust women anymore
uh-oh you stupid fuck you know what if
he got mugged by one person he done
trusting people every exactly I mean I
one person was a murderer let's not
trust anybody yeah yeah you know I heard
about Ted Bundy I'm not trusting people
anymore
okay great I'm not sleeping tonight we
yeah I mean there's definitely pitfalls
in life you're gonna run into him we all
are no you can learn and grow if you
survive you pick yourself up you dust
the dust off and then you start going
and I don't let this stuff don't let it
beat you down it's also directly
proportionate to the amount of hardships
that people face in life their ability
to face hardships you know and there's a
lot of folks that live life on a cushy
cloud of marshmallows and bullshit and
then one day something goes wrong and I
mean that's why spoiled kids are so sad
like a spoiled young boy is one of the
saddest things ever a young boy that
becomes a man and can't take care of
himself and his dad has to keep on
rescuing him his dad has to keep on
bailing them out of situations and
giving them money I've met guys like
that and that is a crippling affliction
when they don't have the character
themselves to be able to get by in life
they constantly need someone to help
them and bail them out even as a grown
man I've met guys in their 40s that
still need help from their parents I'm
like what the fuck man you're never
going to get it right because some
where along the line they didn't face
enough of the adversity to realize that
there's sometimes you just got to get up
and get shit done there's sometimes we
have to fucking pull yourself up and you
have to push forward even if you want to
stay in bed and if you don't do that you
just keep calling on your daddy and your
daddy keeps rescuing you
you never develop those tools you never
develop that ability to recognize what
you're doing wrong with your life
because you're you're soft you got a
cushiony you got a safety net a safety
net for your safety net I have this
friend and she has this uh this friend
that she's been friends with for decades
and his poor fuck his family super super
super wealthy like unbelievable wealthy
billions of dollars and he had that not
only did he had he had a trust fund and
a backup trust fund so he blew through
the trust fund and then he blew through
the backup trust fund real estate
investments and just disastrous business
ventures no character no discipline no
ability to stick it out but incredible
amount of resources he had millions and
millions of dollars just pissed it all
away didn't understand it completely
depressed in one day said to her he said
you know cuz she has children as well
and she has sons he said to where he
goes whatever you do do not give your
kids money don't give them a fucking
penny goes especially your boys don't
give them a penny that ruined me don't
give money wow it's deep shit to be a
man like in your late 40s looking back
at your life this disaster wreckage that
you've put forth with the millions
you've blown now he has like a retail
job
his parents fucking abandon them I mean
you look at that and you go whoa this is
this is wild shit man
so guys she's still struggling from the
way he was developed from the the tools
that were instilled in him at a
childhood and in you know in adolescence
and having that safety net just provided
him with a way to stay in bed kept him
weak never developed character now or
they have an opportunity every time
things go wrong every time things feel
terrible you have an opportunity to
learn from whatever makes you feel
terrible and never allow it to happen
again
exactly yeah thank you that was forward
don't don't do it again yeah you know
learn from your mistakes
we all make them that's where meditation
comes in
recognizing that and solidifying it in
your head and I believe meditation the
tank which is more magnified form of
meditation I think it's more intense and
I think that you can you could really
get something out of that if with those
sort of ideas in mind about constant
consistent improvement and it's only the
only thing that you'll allow from
yourself is to maintain a certain
standard then consistently try to
improve and do that do that and you'll
be a happier person
that's an amazing concept there to
become a part of to where you're
involved in your the construction of
your own character yes through your own
efforts and your own evaluation and then
to to make the right steps and make the
right decisions that you become even
stronger as you go yeah engineering your
life it can be done you know it's not
it's not impossible you can do it to a
certain extent certain extent you can do
it the world could be a better place
crash right it's becoming a better place
becoming analysis but everybody's part
error is to do is to hopefully make it a
little bit better you know if we could
all get on that just do that together
try to make things a little bit better
just a little bit better it would really
have a monsters effect
I agree and I want to thank you I want
to thank you for coming on the podcast
and talking about the stuff and I really
want to thank you for being this guy
who's out there innovating in this you
know almost forgotten business because
for me knowing you has been very
important it's helped me a lot and
knowing your tanks and being aware of
that you know there's a guy out there
that's pushing it so far he's created
this incredible portal I think of it I
mean I know what it is it's a tank
filled with water I know there's a
heater attached and I know there's
filters and I know but for me it's a
portal I get in that fucking thing and I
transform I travel I go to places yeah
it doesn't mental vehicle takes you
somewhere yeah it does it opens up
passages in your mind to take you to
some pretty extraordinary places so
thank you my brother thank you Joe
you've you know been monumental in my
life and I want to thank you you know
from the bottom my heart did well we
found each other man that's what that's
how that's supposed to work you know you
know we we both let people understand
what the benefits of these things are
and we
benefit from them as well and are
generous with those ideas and spread
those ideas to other people just to let
them know man I'm not making this up you
can you can really get better yeah your
life can fuck it and the people who if
you're perfect right now who are you who
you you strange fuck but I really
believe every lonely and everyone
everyone could benefit from that
everyone so uh if you guys want to go
the float lab is booked up rock-solid
deep into August but the the Brentwood
one who knows when it'll be open
hopefully Westwood scuse me got Brent
one Westwood what's the difference
where's Wesley UCLA okay where's
Brentwood Brentwood is I was confused of
course badges realized which ones more
posh which one is where um Brentwood
brat would is where AJ killed though
yeah allegedly that's real pawn it's
very posh right cause that's why it's
quite shocking
dad I'm not allowed in that neck of the
woods they don't let you in oh I'll talk
to somebody
anyway so will will let you know when
Westwood opens up we'll let you know on
the podcast meanwhile you can follow
crash on Twitter it's the float lab is
the website for for the float lab itself
and you guys have an Instagram - there
we do the Facebook float lab
technologies float lab technologies on
Facebook please like that and follow and
all that good stuff and we're going to
have that chamber to do something with
there soon in the near future cool my
old chamber we'll figure out some sort
of a contest and give that bitch away
will be the second time of giving away a
chamber I'm very excited about that
alright ladies and gentlemen we'll be
back tomorrow with the full charge mat
full tron will be in the house and
that's it alright till then much love
big kiss